während der corona-krise ist der
Alkoholkonsum gestiegen besonders unter
Berufstätigen wer ist eine neue Studie
zeigt die Mehrheit sagt sie können so
besser den Stress abbauen und auch die
Kranken Tage wegen Alkohol erreichen
einen Höchststand während Corona
trinkhalation Deutschland Frust trinken
statt Genuss trinken heckklässler
abschalten mit einem Glas Rotwein willst
du da schon gefährlich ich hoffe nicht
weil ich das sehr oft mache also ich
komme aus der Pfalz ich trinke gerne
Weinen das gehört für mich auch schon
zum zum Genuss dazu aber wie geht's dir
glaube ich um wirklich schweren
Alkoholgenuss Alkohol Missbrauch
teilweise schon und bewerbungswert ist
natürlich schon dass es vor allem die
Berufstätigen in diesem Falle trifft
also nicht die jetzt unter den Brücken
liegen also die nichts mehr erwarten von
mir 30 und 39 dann Anstieg um fast 89 %.
unsere Leistungselite im Leben steht
vielleicht Familie hat nicht mehr den
ersten Job sondern zweiten schon hat
Karriereschritt